-LL, here we are.
I want to talk about this
Furious Five Challenge
that you've been doing
on Instagram.
-Yeah.
-Like, how did it start?
And what is
the idea of the game?
Can I play?
-The idea of the game is --
you have a furious five seconds
to go -- to find five items.
And you have five seconds each.
So, you know, and
you have to go find an item,
whatever item
I name in five seconds.
You know what I'm saying?
-This is tough.
-Huh?
-This is tough
a little bit for me,
because I don't know
if you have this,
but when I got married,
all of my stuff left.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-All my stuff is gone.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your stuff -- it starts
disappearing, right?
-Yeah. I don't see it anymore.
But I'm in, like,
kind of a work room,
so I can find things that if
you give me something,
I can find something.
-Alright.
Okay, I'll give you a
furious five seconds
to find a dog chew toy --
1,000 points.
-A dog -- A chew toy?
-Yeah, a chew toy.
1,001, 1,002...
-Aah!
-...1,003,
1,004, 1,005,
[ Imitates buzzer ]
Oh, yeah, that might have been
a buzzer-beater.
That might have been
Okay, that's a buzzer-beater.
You almost missed that one.
-You got to give me that Zoom --
Extra second for Zoom.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-You know what I got?
It's because I have a tennis
balls all over the house.
-Oh -- Oh, so a tennis ball.
So that's the chew toy.
-My dog loves tennis balls,
and she walks around just even
just holds it in her mouth
and just, like...
and just, like, walks around,
like, and then just drops them.
This one I could throw away.
-I love that. I love that.
-This one's janky, but
that one's --
So, that's -- These are just
strown around my house.
-So, you're in an office.
I want you to find
one more thing.
-Yep.
-Find something from
Winnie and Franny, anything.
-Okay, that's easy.
-Yeah.
-1-1,000.
2-1,000.
3-1,000.
-I got this.
I got two things.
-What's that?
What's that? Let me see.
Let me see. Let me see.
-Alright, this is
a drawing from Winnie.
-That's pretty amazing,
actually.
-That looks like
a unicorn cat or something.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
A uni-cat.
-A uni-cat.
She's created a new animal.
-That's a new character
on the show -- the uni-cat.
I love the uni-cat.
We love the uni-cat.
-The uni-cat
can be the new thing.
-The uni-cat is the new thing.
You just got to
cut the mouth out
and then let the uni-cat --
Whatever the uni-cat wants to
talk about,
the uni-cat can talk about.
I love it.
-Alright. Alright.
That's -- See?
That's what I'm talk--
Already, I'm inspired.
I also grabbed --
I grabbed a drawing
that I drew when I was a kid.
I got -- I put --
This is called "Peace."
-That's hilarious.
Oh, and you got the --
Oh, he got the black dude
in there and the "peace."
[ Both laugh ]
I love it. I love it.
-I only got a "good."
-Oh, you only got a "good."
Wow! [ Laughs ]
That's funny.
You only got "good."
I think it's pretty good,
actually.
-Come on, peace? Peace is great.
-I like that.
-How about this?
Can I do one for you?
-Alright.
Alright, I'll play with you.
-Find me the last pair of
sneakers you wore.
-Alright.
-1-1,000.
[ Laughs ]
2-1,000.
3-1,000.
4-1,000.
Oh! He did it!
What are those ones?
-Those are MCM Pumas.
-Wow!
-They're MCM Pumas.
-Look at those ones.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Oh!
-And then I got another pair.
Let me see.
-Oh!
-You know what I mean?
-Whoo!
-You know what I'm saying?
These are kind of cool, too.
You know, no ads
here, ladies and gentlemen.
This is just --
-No, no, no, no, no.
This is just fun,
just us having fun.
-You know me.
I think these
are pretty cool, too.
I know -- It's funny.
I look at them on the Zoom.
They look brand-new,
but they're not.
They look, like, completely new,
which is crazy.
-I dig it.
I like those colors, man.
LL, I can't thank you enough
for coming on the show.
It means a lot to me.
-Thank you, man.
-Best to the fam. Hugs.
I can't wait to see you
in person,
because you know
I love you, man.
Congrats in everything.
-Thank you, man.
I appreciate it. One love, baby.
-Bye, bud.
-Peace.